So another way to think about the proof of the folk theorem, is you
could prove it with a little strategy that is referred to as grim trigger.
>> Mm. I like that. I like the way it sounds.
>> So here's, here's the basic structure of grim trigger. It says that
what we're going to do, is we're going to start off, taking some kind of action
or pattern of actions, it's a mutual benefit. And as long as it's
cooperation continues this mutual beneficial, behavior will
continue. But however, if you ever cross
the line, and fail to cooperate with me.
Then I will deal out vengeance against you forever.
>> Hm, so once again, we're talking about my
ex girlfriends. I don't know why you're obsessed with this.
>> [LAUGH] Maybe it's just, maybe it's just trying to help
you understand. So you know kind of what this situation is.
Anyways here's, here's what that looks like in the context of
prisoners dilemma. Alright so cooperation is
the, is the mutually beneficial action.
>> Yes.
>> And as long as you continue to
cooperate with me, that's this C arrow here, then
I will continue to cooperate with you, but if
you ever defect on me, I swear I will
spend the rest of my life making you pay. So no matter what you do at this
point, defect of cooperate, I will just continue to
defect on you. Pain will rain from the sky.
>> Okay, well this makes sense. So, the idea here
is that if you know that I"m going to do this,
then hopefully it makes sense for us to continue to mutually benefit.
>> Right. So the whole purpose of this is
to create, a, a Nash Equilibrium System kind of situation.
Right? Where if I'm playing this strategy. And you're playing
this strategy, then neither of us has any incentive to
cross the line, and so we're just going to continue
to cooperate. Crossing the line is going to decrease your
reward, so there's no benefit to doing it, so you
won't do it. So it, it's nice because it gets
us a Nash Equilibrium.
>> Hm.
>> But there's a problem with it.
>> Of course.
>> And you pointed it out before, so let's, let's dive in and
make sure that we understand it and see if we can fix it.
>> Okay.